okay hello everyone welcome to another
episode of Science and Technology a for
kids and others and I see all kinds of
questions stored up here so let's see
start off with the first one from Stefan
can you tell us some not widely known
insights about prime
numbers uh this is a case where uh
having being able to actually use
Mathematica Mor from language and show
you stuff would help a lot but I I'll
say a few things um I'm not going to do
the share screen thing here today all
right what is a prime number
well
uh you could think about it in in the
following kind of way imagine that you
were making a number let's say 12 and
you were making a rectangle that whose
area was 12 and the sides of the
rectangle should be some integer some
whole number you're making bunch of
putting together 12 squares to make a
rectangle can you do that well yes you
can do it you can have something where
there are three squares on one side and
four squares on the other side 3 * 4 is
equal to 12 you make that rectangle
question is can you make a rectangle
like that for any number let's think
about the number seven for example well
think about six that's two * 3 that's
all good think about 8 that's 2 * 4 or 4
* 2 or whatever
uh think about um well if we take 12 for
example that's either 2 * 6 or 3 * 4 or
whatever we can make our rectangle try
and do it for seven you can't do it the
and that that's that's seven is a number
that can't be made by making something
times something equals seven the only
thing you can do that with is is one and
seven 1 * 7 is 7even but there's no two
* anything three times anything that
makes seven okay
so that's for those who don't know it
that's what prime numbers are and some
numbers are prime two is prime three is
prime five is Prime Seven is prime uh 11
is prime 13 is prime Etc and so first
question is are there an infinite number
of
primes that there's one if one wants
numbers that have this property that
they can't be broken down as multiplying
together other numbers will you always
have numbers will there always be
numbers which are prime answer yes that
was something that was known to uid
actually in uh in Antiquity a couple of
thousand years ago there are an infinite
number of primes and there's there's
there's probably some nice ways I'm
wonder if I could verbally prove that
there are infinite number of primes let
me think about that
um um oh let me try not try doing that
right now uh there's I was thinking of
ucl's proof which is a little bit tricky
to explain um but there's an there's an
easier
proof
that uh has to do with kind of thinking
about the information content of numbers
but let let's let's not worry about it
first first statement is there an
infinite number of prime numbers they
keep going forever okay next question
there are some some when you look at the
prime numbers there's like two and three
those are only one apart that's never
going to repeat the the the
maximum closeness of primes further on
is two apart so 11 and
um uh what's the next
um uh what's the next what's called twin
Prime primes which are just one apart
but two apart so to speak like 11 and 13
um five and seven another uh twin Prime
pair okay so a question that you can ask
is okay there infinite number of primes
what about twin primes are there an
infinite number of twin primes that's a
question people asked a couple of
thousand years ago and nobody knows the
answer there's people have tried to
compute twin primes and yes you can keep
going there are very big twin primes but
are there an infinite number of twin
primes the answer to that is not known
and it's it's one of these problems it's
one of the older unsolved problems in
mathematics is are there an infinite
number of twin primes
so we think about the prime numbers and
there are all kinds of obvious questions
we might ask like what fraction of
numbers are prime and the answer is that
as you get to bigger numbers the
fraction that a prime goes down there
are more ways that the number could be
written as a as a product multiplying
together other numbers so the density of
primes goes down and and roughly as you
get to size n prime numbers of of uh
size n the density is goes down like the
logarithm of n so it's kind of like if
you look at uh the
um uh
your it sort of slowly goes down it goes
down the rate at which it goes down is
sort of proportional to the number of
digits in the number the number itself
like when you get you know between 100
and a th000 you've got 900 uh you've
you've got 900 numbers but you only are
going up by one digit adding on that
that extra extra digit to represent the
thousands column and so on and the the
density of prime numbers kind of goes
down slowly just by sort of looking at
the number of digits and numbers not the
actual sizes of numbers so one of the
things that has been uh a long running
thing that people have tried to do is to
prove What's called the prime number
theorem which is the estimate of what
the density of primes actually is and
turns out that's it's roughly goes like
this logarithm then a little bit more
accurately like a log integral function
and then a little bit more accurately
than that it goes down with this formula
that depends on this thing called the
reman zeta function and the reman zeta
function something invented in the 18 I
think 1859 if I remember correctly um is
uh a um uh it's a mathematical function
and has a formula and there's a pretty
straightforward formula for it Zeta of s
is the sum of 1/ N the s for n going
from one to Infinity so for example Z of
2 is 1 over 1 2 + 1 over 2 2 + 1 over 3
2qu + 1 over 4 squ and so on up to
Infinity that particular case Zeta of 2
happens to be equal to pi^ S over 6 Zeta
of 3 you can't express it in terms of
Pies Zeta of four happens to be Pi 4
over 90 etc etc etc okay so what's
related to prime numbers is not Zeta of
two or three or four but um Zeta of a
complex number so you can take that that
kind of the the function which is can be
defined uh by that by that sum and you
can continue that function outside of
just ordinary positive numbers and so on
and you can continue it even to complex
numbers numbers which include things
like the square root of minus one and so
on and when you look at that you're
asking that that zeta function thing has
zeros there are values of s and Zeta of
s there are values of s for which Zeta
of s is equal to zero and the prime
number theorem the thing that gives you
this estimate of the density of primes
um is has a particular form if and only
if the zeros of the zeta function lie on
this thing called the critical line
critical line is a line in the complex
plane it's it's s equals a half plus I
times some quantity T and I'm getting a
bit technical here but basically the
when you make a plot of the zeta
function you'll see it Wiggles around
like crazy and the question is when does
it hit zero and the the answer is that
uh so far as we can tell for the first
um let's see about um 100 billion I
think it's known zeros of the zeta
function all lie on this critical line
so they all have this feature that they
uh are in the place that they need to be
so that this prime number theorem that
gives you the estimate of the density of
primes is correct but we don't know for
sure that the um that the zero Z
function all lie on that on that line
that's a thing called the reman
hypothesis that's been an open problem
for more than 150 years now of showing
that that's true or not and the rean
hypothesis is is kind of one of the big
sort of exciting unsolved problems of
mathematics it's an interesting problem
because it kind of relates questions
about numbers to questions about
mathematical functions to questions
about actually things including geometry
and other areas it's kind of a meeting
point for a lot of different kinds of uh
areas of
mathematics
it there's a question even of whether
given the axioms the assumptions we make
about what's true in mathematics things
like that if you have two numbers X and
Y that X Plus Y is the same as y + x
that's an axiom that's an assumption
about how addition works for any numbers
X and Y well there are a collection it's
fairly small number of standard axioms
that one uses to uh to sort of build up
mathematics as we know it today and
there's a question of whether those
axioms are sufficient
to answer the question of whether the
reman hypothesis is true could it be the
case that the reman hypothesis is
somehow not provable from those axioms
and that seems like it's a serious
possibility that it could be something
which which knowing whether it's true is
something where you kind of have to do
all this sort of infinite computation
and you can't do that and you can't sort
of ever reach the point of saying yes we
know it's true just from these a
and in fact it turns out that the reman
hypothesis is you can you can write it
as something which doesn't involve Zeta
functions things like that it's just a
question about something where you're
doing a sort of iteration of integers so
there's a very famous problem called the
3 n plus1 problem where you're saying
take a number n let's say it's 100 and
if if n is even divide it by two so you
get 50 in that case if n is odd compute
3 n + one um and and so that would be in
this case if we get if it was odd it
would be let's say it was oh boy this is
going to this is going to tax my
mathematical abilities this is why I
build uh this is why I've spent my life
building systems that do things
automatically it's because I'm pretty
bad at doing this myself so but let's
say it was 99 okay that's not an even
number then we compute 3 n+ one I think
I can manage that that's 300 - 3 so 297
+ 1 298 so 9 9 would go to 298 and so on
you just iterate keep and so 298 then
you just divide that by two and you keep
iterating this so the 3 n plus1 problem
the big question is does it always end
in does it always get down to well it
ends up with a little cycle of numbers
one and four and so on at the end does
it always get down to that or could it
be the case that you're Computing 3n
plus one and somehow you end up getting
bigger and bigger and bigger numbers
because you keep on hitting the 3n Plus
one thing rather than the n/2 thing and
it sort of escapes to Infinity Nobody
Knows the answer to that turns out that
there is a version of the ran hypothesis
that looks a very a lot like that it's
more complicated than just 3n plus one
it's a formula I actually sort of tried
to compress the formula for this uh a
couple years ago and you can get it down
to something that's you know I think
about one line of or language code um of
just sort of simple mathematical
functions on whole numbers and and then
the rean hypothesis becomes this
question of if you do this iteration
will it always terminate so those are
those are a few things now you ask about
about sort of other things about primes
another question about primes that
surprisingly
unanswered is what the I mentioned twin
primes or they primes that are just two
apart there a question of how far apart
typically are primes and that turns out
to be something that's been investigated
empirically there's not a lot known
about that if you look at the early
primes the most common distance apart to
find primes is six if you keep looking
at bigger and bigger bigger primes
you'll find that the distance apart the
average distance apart goes up a bit um
but that distribution there's a definite
kind of distribution of how far apart
typically are primes and it's not well
understood how that works so it's sort
of a remarkable thing because primes are
pretty easy to Define yet there are
already kind of questions about them
that are surprisingly hard to answer and
may not even be answerable from the kind
of assumptions we've so far made in
math okay here's one more thing about
primes how easy is it to figure out if a
number is prime well when it comes to
factoring numbers taking some number I
don't know 102 and saying what are the
prime factors of 102 how do you break
102 into well let's take one I can
actually do in my head 33 Okay 33 is
equal to 3 * 11 okay how do you know how
do you take a number and figure out what
its factors are so one way you can do it
is if if you guess the factors and you
guessed one of them right then the
number is going to start unraveling
because you can just divide by that
factor you can keep going and you get
the factors but knowing whether a um
whether a number is uh sort of guessing
the factors of a number if you guess
them right you can you can uh you can
sort of unravel it but systematically
going from the number to its factors
seems to be pretty hard
and the type of problem where you
can sort of once you guess the answer
it's easy to solve the problem these are
so-called NP problems it stands for
non-deterministic polinomial time what
does that mean that means as you look at
so you take a problem like I don't know
multiplying numbers together okay you
have an igit number and you ask the
question how long does it take to
multiply one igit number by another igit
number the way they teach you in school
for doing long multiplication it takes
about n * n steps n squ steps turns out
there are methods for multiplying
numbers that do it in N log log n type
steps very very close to N steps those
are the things we use in W from language
for example to do large number
multiplication it's very not like you do
it in the sort of school book
multiplication method it's a a very
different kind of method that uh just
for for sort of uh the you know the
fancy statement is it uses uh um fora
transforms to to do these these
computations that's that's at least an
approach to doing it but any case and by
the way the reason that sort of
schoolbook multiplication is you don't
it doesn't need to take that long is
that in sort of the schoolbook
multiplication method you're multiplying
every digit by every other digit but it
turns out as you do that you're kind of
doing many digits you're doing many
multiplications more times than you need
to there's ways to sort of compress the
number of multiplications and that's how
those kind of methods work but so
multiplying numbers together is a is an
operation which as you increase the
length of the numbers at best it goes up
like n squ where n is the length of the
numbers it's a a polinomial in n and um
so that uh uh so if if you are given the
factors of a number multiplying them all
together to check that yes indeed those
factors multiply together to make the
number that's something that uh you can
do with computational effort that scales
just with roughly with the length of the
the the number of digits in the number
okay but let's take the other question
of taking a number and figuring out what
its factors are well one way you can
figure that out is just say let me guess
that it might have two as a factor let
me guess it might have three as a factor
four as a factor five is a factor and so
on and just keep on trying to divide the
number by successive integers okay
that's a way you can guarantee to find
out what the factors of the number are
the only problem is if your number is uh
if you have a some some number it has
100 digits for example you the amount of
effort it takes is about the size of the
number so it's 10 to the 100 uh step
let's say you have a number a a number
that's in the Millions you have to you
have to uh sort of try dividing by every
number less than that number to see
whether anything divides it's very
different from multiplying the number
where all you have to look at is the
number of digits which is six as opposed
to the size of the number which is a
million and so these these problems that
have this feature that if you can guess
the answer well this particular case the
only sort of the very systematic way to
work out what are the factors of number
is you do trying you try to div div it
by numbers up to the actual size of that
number and that will take if the number
has n digits that could take like 10 the
power
n uh steps because there are 10 to the N
numbers that are up to the size of the
number so to speak so if if for example
for for the millions uh you know million
is is uh is 10 the^ six so there are six
digits for 1 million six zeros um but
the the actual number is a million okay
so this question of factoring um it's a
problem where if you could just say I
know the answer it's this you could
check it easily but to systematically
find the answer you have to go through
lots and lots of steps to to find that
answer and one of the big questions is
this P versus NP question are all
problems that where if you guess the
answer you can check it quickly do they
is it possible that every every time you
have a problem where you could guess the
answer and check it quickly that in fact
there is an algorithm for solving that
problem that can systematically do it
quickly it is strongly believed that
there are plenty of problems which have
the property that just because you can
check them quickly doesn't mean you can
compute them quickly and it's believed
that factoring is an example of that
it's beli that to work out the uh the
factors of a number in general is in
some sense is hard I I was going to say
exponentially hard but it's it's known
not to be quite exponentially hard
exponentially in the if you've got a
number of length n does it take like 2
to the N or 10 to the N or something
steps to do it it's not quite as bad as
that but it's not something which is a
polinomial in N so far as one could tell
so in other words factoring seems to be
a hard problem to take a number and
grind it down to its factors seems to be
a hard problem it is uh not there there
are class of problems that are in this
class NP problems that where the answer
is easy to check but it's not obvious
how you systematically get to that
answer there are class of so-called NP
complete problems which have the feature
that if you could only solve one of them
you can translate it into all the other
problems there are problems about graphs
there are problems about numbers etc etc
etc if you could solve just one NP
complete problem there's a translation
to all other NP complete problems and so
there's kind of a a stren strengthen
numbers in the sense that that people
have tried picking away at different
ones of these MP complete problems
nobody's ever managed to find a fast way
to solve any of them and so it's
believed that they're all hard to solve
factoring isn't known to be MP complete
it's what's called NP hard um so it
doesn't it doesn't get the benefit of
kind of that herd of NP complete
problems but it's still probably has
this property that it can't be solved
quickly okay surprising fact is that
testing whether a number is prime can be
solved quickly so taking a number and
breaking it down into primes seems to be
hard to do but if you give me a number
testing whether that number is prime
turns out to be something you can do
rather quickly and actually the the uh
the thing that allows you to do that it
starts from a thing called format's
little theorem people may have heard of
format's Last Theorem which was this
which is this uh uh result in number
theory that that says if you have x y
and z are three integers that for
example we know that x^2 + y^2 = z^2
there are values of X Y and Z that make
that true for example uh 3 45 3^2 + 42 =
5^2 9 + 16 = 25 uh similarly uh 5 12 13
is another one of these so-called
Pythagorean triples so they were known
to Pythagoras that solves the problem X
x^2 + y^2 = z^2 for whole numbers X Y
and Z okay so then the question is what
if you instead of doing squared you say
it's X cubed + y cubed = z cubed there
are no known solutions to that for
positive numbers positive whole numbers
X Y and Z in fact in that particular
case it's been known for a long time you
can prove that it's not possible to find
numbers X Y and Z that solve that so
format's Last Theorem is this question
of whether x to the n plus y the N equal
Z to the N for n greater than two
whether there are solutions to that and
that was something that was
um uh was not um uh it was for many many
years that was a a big sort of Unsolved
problem is it is it people had looked
for Solutions and never found them
finally in the in the early 1990s it was
proved with a surprisingly elaborate
proof that no there really aren't any
possible solutions to that that's forat
Last Theorem format mus Pi de fat from
the 1600s had a thing called the his
little theorem which is uh a theorem
that says
that uh well a power of a number modern
other number has to have a certain
result and that that
formula um says it has to have a certain
result when the thing that appears in it
is a prime number it says if the thing
is a prime number then uh some a number
some some integer pick an integer raise
it to an a power and that power is a
prime and then uh take that mod I think
I'm remembering this correctly take that
mod um uh another number then if that if
that number that appears there is a
prime the result has to be one if it
isn't a prime then but it's still could
be the case that some number other than
a prime could give result one but if
it's a prime it always has to give a
result one so if the result was two then
you know that number isn't a prime so
the idea is you can probabilistically
test for primality by saying let's just
pick different numbers for that base
there and try taking the number that we
have that's our candidate Prime and
raise That Base to the power of that
Prime and compute this this mod thing
and see what the result is and if we say
for any particular base we say the
numberers one okay that's evidence that
this thing that we fed in could be a
prime if the number comes out to be two
the game is over we know our number
isn't Prime but so you can try feeding
in a bunch of different numbers and see
a bunch of different bases and see
whether for each of those the thing
comes out with one and says okay it
could be a prime so people had known for
a long time it's sort of an interesting
case well had known since the
1970s I think that uh this there was
this sort of probabilistic test for
primality where you can just try uh try
different numbers against your candidate
Prime and say could this be a prime
could this be a prime and if it's yes
yes yes yes yes this could be a prime if
there are enough times you say yes yes
yes it could be a prime then you might
get more and more convinced yes it
really is a prime okay sometime in when
was this probably 15 years ago now
finally some people showed that if you
do that enough times more or less and
you do a few extra things as well then
you can nail down and say yes this
number I have is a prime and the effort
to do that is vastly less than the
effort to try and factor a number so
primality testing testing whether a
number is prime is something to be done
quite
quickly so there are actually the
um uh for example you can ask the
question another type of question you
can ask is what's the millionth Prime
what's the 10 millionth Prime what's the
100 millionth Prime you might have
thought that if you say what's the
billionth prime or whatever that that
would be a lot of effort to work out
because you have to you know you might
think you'd have to go through all the
Primes up to the billionth Prime and see
which one is going to be that that
billionth Prime the billion of first
Prime and so on turns out that's not
necessary it turns out there's a trick
that relates to the ruman zeta function
remember I mentioned that the Run zeta
function is related to the density of
prime
well if you can get an accurate enough
estimate of the density of primes you
can work out up to this size how many
primes will there be up to the size if
you estimated the density how many
primes there are per number so to speak
you know that well enough then
eventually you can kind of nail down how
many primes must there be up to this
size and so it turns out it's actually
can get easier to work out the um uh you
know what well almost easier at least to
work out what the the 10 billionth Prime
is than than some smaller prime using
using that method of doing estimates
okay my last uh I'm doing sort of free
association about things to do with
primes another big question it's been a
long running question about primes is is
there a formula for primes that is is
there a mathematical formula that you
can write down where you know that every
number that you can get out of this
formula is a prime so for example format
himself uh had um
a candidate for that well there's a chap
called menen who is kind of a
contemporary formats who has a more
famous version of this
um which is a number of the form 2 to
the N minus one I think am I remember I
think the format version is 2 to the 2
to the N plus one minus one I'm not sure
this is the kind of thing W from
language knows that immediately I my
brain doesn't know that immediately um
but any case their numbers of of the
form roughly things like 2 to the N
minus one uh 2 to the N is obviously not
a prime because it's just divisible by
two but 2 the N minus one might be a
prime and sometimes it is a prime and
sometimes it's not a prime and people
had wondered was it always going to be a
prime and people had wondered could
there be a formula could there is a
finite formula we can write down that is
just like every we we has some parameter
let's say n in it and we just compute
this whole thing with you know 2 to the
N minus 3 to the whatever plus whatever
plus whatever that that formula will
always give primes so far as it's known
there is no such formula I don't think
there's any proof that no such formula
can exist um although I
think I think it's let me think
uh yeah I um yeah no I don't think I
don't think one knows I don't think one
has really a way well let me think I
mean if if you say it can only contain
arithmetic operations I suspect that is
provable but I'm not not sure that
that's actually proved um you can
certainly make up uh
equations like that one I was mentioning
X2 + y^2
z^2 that are equations involving
integers you can make an equation
involving integers where the only
solution to that equation is primes and
you don't have to have any fancy things
about mods and anything like that you
can just have an arithmetic formula that
is a complicated polinomial formula
equals zero let's say and the only
numbers that will solve that uh are are
primes uh that was something that was
established in the
1960s um there are also other weird
things for example if you have even just
polinomial
um then and you allow numbers that
aren't necessarily just positive numbers
you allow positive and negative numbers
and you ask for what numbers is this
polinomial you have positive uh there
are cases there that at least I've found
where at least seems to be the case that
you get only uh that the only numbers
that satisfy that are prime numbers and
I'm not sure I know
why all right a few a few comments about
prime
numbers
um
let's
see
uh
um some questions about about prime
numbers let me just see
uh
JH asks are the is the distance between
P twin primes now quite well known yeah
you can certainly compute you know with
wolam language I'm sure we can
compute uh up to I don't know how many
digit primes 3040 digits I don't know
maybe bigger than that um and uh we can
certainly look at experimentally what is
the distance between twin primes um and
yes the the the distance between prime
numbers like the distance between uh
twin primes has some distribution which
gradually gets broader it gradually
further and further between between um
numbers between prime numbers and that's
that's reflected in this prime number
theorem which says that the density of
primes gradually Goes Down And there are
similar much more elaborate versions of
that
um uh that um
um that have uh that involve twin
primes let's
see uh okay Seb
asks what does the kind of factoring
that you learn in an Algebra 2 class
actually have to do with real
life all right let's talk about that
so let me give some
examples
about
uh well prime numbers where they show up
so
on
um here's an example
so uh let's see how to make this work
well it has to do with Saturn Saturn has
these Rings you see through a telescope
they look really cool there they're
they're kind of like it's kind of like
the the sun has a bunch of planets going
around which are all lie in one plane
when when the solar system was formed
there was an accretion dis of just stuff
that was all sort of spinning around the
central uh Mass which was the Sun and
gradually th that accretion disc formed
into it it sort of formed into lanes and
those kind of eventually condensed into
planets okay so uh
planets have moons going around them
that are kind of like little tiny solar
systems where there are usually in the
plane of in a particular plane that's
usually aligned with the plane of the
orbit of the planets there are there are
moons going around and of course then
you can ask are there Moon moons where
there are moons going around moons going
around planets where and the planets are
then going around the Sun and the Moon
moons are uh still a controversial kind
of issue uh because their orbits don't
tend to be get be stable but any case
the um uh so around Saturn there are not
only are there actual moons a whole
bunch of them but there also it's just
random little pieces of ice and rock and
so on which are all like an accretion
disc they're all forming this dis in the
plane of the of the planet okay but if
you look at Saturn's rings they have
little gaps in them and the um and the
question is what are those gaps
and the this is a this is a story of
about numbers and um let's see roughly
the point is
this
that
um well okay you have a a moon going
around a planet and it is exerting a
gravitational force on other
things if you
have how am I going to explain this
essentially what happens is if the if
you have two things going around the
planet and one of them goes around uh
takes two days to go around and the
other takes three days to go around then
most of the time they won't sort of be
in the same place around the planet at
the same time but every so often if one
takes two days and one takes three days
every so often uh sort of the let's say
say in that example um let me think
uh I'm thinking it's six days that right
yes yes after six days one of the
planets will have gone around three
times the other planet will have gone
around two times and they'll both wind
up in the same place so that leads to
what's called a resonance where you kind
of get these two things that are that
are uh sort of going around and they
they end up in the same place and how do
you avoid that how do you make it be the
case that they don't end up in the same
place well those numbers need to be
relatively prime it needs to be the case
that there's no multiple of one of the
numbers that's equal to the other number
so for example if we have um
uh let me see
if well it's again I'm sorry this is
this is a you're asking me things with
numbers you're asking math things which
are very easy to compute um with uh our
fine technology but but not so easy to
just talk about um but let me let me
just sort of so one example you're
asking where do things like primes and
so on show up one example uh is in
things like the the the gaps in the in
the rings of Saturn having to do with
these particular kind of numerical
coincidences of where where things line
up with with periods of of uh of how
long it takes moons to go around that's
one example let me pick a um let me pick
a different example
um well there's a there's a kind of
bizarrely related example also
about
um let me
think uh yeah I mean this is so I think
I shouldn't go in this direction because
it's so much easier to do maybe some
sometime I'll ask me again about these
these things when I'm actually doing uh
something where we're actually typing on
a computer because I think it's it's
going to get difficult to describe these
things but let me go in a different
direction with with prime numbers uh and
and
factoring the big sort of application
area for factoring that people talk
about a lot is public key
cryptography so let me try to explain
that so what is cryptography
cryptography is take your message like
uh uh you know um sort
of the invasion is going to be by sea or
something take that message and you want
to grind it up into some form that looks
random to somebody who just finds the
message lying on the on the sidewalk
somewhere but where the correct
recipient of that message has a key that
allows them to to decode the message and
find out you know the invasion will be
by C or something um and uh so the
earliest kinds of forms of cryptography
that people know about there's a thing
called the Caesar Cipher that was
probably used by Julius Caesar and what
what was done there is you take a a
piece of text like uh the well C sea
okay you take those those letters
obviously for um for Caesar it would be
Mar because it'll be in Latin um but uh
uh the um um so but let's take it in
English sea and our code is just going
to be let's add two to the letter so in
the alphabet we go St T so we'd say add
to we'd get U the E would be G and then
the a would be C so we'd get
ugc and so
you pick up this this message and it
says ugc and you don't know what that
means unless you know the number two in
which case you just say well I'm going
to subtract two from each of those
letters and then I get sea and that was
the the kind of Cipher that
um uh is it said Julius Caesar used and
you know I think it was a time when when
not that many people could read to begin
with let alone could kind of figure out
oh you can subtract from these these
letters and so on very simple Cipher the
key is the offset and that's sort of how
you you need to know that key in order
to be able to do the decoding okay years
later people started using so-call
running key ciphers where instead of
just adding two to each letter so to
speak going two steps in the alphabet
you would go first two steps then four
steps then six steps then eight steps
and so on you would increase the number
of steps you would run the number of
steps up and that was a type of Cipher
that even in the 1600s people had a hard
time breaking people didn't know kind of
How to Think Through sort of how you
would take that message and figure out
what the key was and break
it okay so then we get to much later um
in for example the time of the second
world war and so on um and one had sort
of elaborated versions of running key
ciphers that involved rotor Wheels where
you would have all the letters of the
alphabet on some wheel and you would
click it up and you would uh and these
wheels would have letters in different
order and you would have this way of
kind of having a an electrical kind of
plug board where you would kind of
randomly permute things and things that
made for example this thing called the
Enigma machine which was used by by
Germany in World War II and was famously
broken by the British and people like
Alan Turing were involved in that and
what did it mean to break it well what
it meant was there was a key that was
set every day you would have to
everybody you know at every every field
commander in the army or something uh
there would be some Courier who would
tell them this is going to be the key of
the day and so then they would set that
key on their on their uh encryption
machine and decryption machine and then
everything they would send out will be
encrypted with that key the things they
would get in they would use that key to
decrypt
things and so the the what what had to
be done was to figure out well what was
the key now you know there were lots of
possible keys so it wasn't easy to just
go through and try all the possible Keys
it's kind of like passwords in modern
times if you have a long password you'd
have to try a lot of passwords before
You' get to the one that you actually
used that is unless you pick a password
which is like your data birth or your or
the name of your favorite names of
animals or something which is a much
smaller set of possibilities than a
password that has oh you know uppercase
letters and lowercase letters and it's
all a jumbled mess so to speak then the
only way to find the password is
basically just to try all the
possibilities until you get there and
the longer the password the more
possibilities there are so okay so one
way so kind of the idea was to break the
Enigma machine to break the the code you
have to try the keys and find a key that
works okay so what happened in uh
Bletchley Park in the codebreaking
effort in in World War II was first of
all they used some technology which was
sort of early pre- electronic computers
actually it came from telephone
switching circuits and things where they
would have machines that would just go
through and systematically try click
click click click trying different
combinations that was first thing the
second thing was figuring out how to
prune down the number of things you have
to try how to know oh it couldn't be one
once you've checked this and this and
this you know you can exclude this and
this and this and this and this and and
reducing the size of the search space to
be able to do the decryption okay but
but so
then that whole idea of of what amounts
to encryption by substitution and
permutation substitution as in you've
got this letter and it's going to be
replaced by that permutation as in you
mix up blocks of letters that idea of
having blocks substitution and
permutation that's been a long running
idea in cryptography and in fact even in
methods that are used today are
basically big messy collections of
substitution and permutation
blocks so that that was sort of the
state-of-the-art in cryptography now one
important feature about those methods is
they're typically set up so that
whatever key you use to encrypt is the
same key that you use to decrypt if you
take the example of old Julia Caesar
let's say you're your key is add two to
the letter well your that's your
encryption key says add two your
decryption key is essentially the same
it's just subtract two it's there's a
there's a and in the case of the
substitution permutation ciphers was
actually the same key it's actually the
same key that is used that allows you to
go both forwards and go backwards okay
so that was kind of the state-of-the-art
of cryptography until sometime the
1970s when uh it was it was that you
would make a a key that would be used
for encryption and also for decryption
and obviously the the issue of how you
distribute the keys is non-trivial
because uh you know if somebody knew
what the key was if somebody intercepted
your career who was delivering the key
and found the key then they don't have
to do any of this script analysis and
and fancy things with computers and so
on they just say up I know the key so um
that was that that's and they know okay
so that that was that story okay then
came the idea of so-called public key
cryptography and the big idea there is
that the key to encrypt is different
from the key to
decrypt and the thing this comes from is
factoring numbers and so sort of the
basic way this works is that roughly the
um well let's see you you're roughly the
the key to encrypt
is a number that's all you need to do
the encryption but if you want to do
decryption you need the factors of the
number and because it's hard to go from
the number to its factors you can't go
from the public key to the private key
okay so what's the point of this well it
means that you can have something where
you say this is my public key you want
to send me a message just encrypt it
with this public key and you can publish
your public key you can put it put it on
your website this is my public key but
if you want to uh if you if you want to
if you want to get your message anybody
can send you a message if you want to
know what that message was you have to
use your private key to decrypt the
message and figure out what what the
message was and the the most popular way
to do this uses so-called RSA
cryptography um which is based on uh the
difficulty of factoring numbers it's
based on this idea that you um
that you can have a public key that's
the number and private keys that are
essentially the prime factors of the
number it gets a little bit more
elaborate and it's actual implementation
but that's basically the idea and it
actually relates to format the little
theorem the thing I mentioned before the
actual way this encryption and
decryption is done but in any case the
the um uh so public key cryptography is
used all over the web and all sorts of
all sorts of places for uh and there are
all sorts of protocols that you can use
in public key cryptography for example
you can make digital signatures you can
say here's this thing I signed it and to
prove that I signed it I have to be able
to show you my I have to do things that
only I can do because I have my private
key and I can do stuff that I can do
with my private key but you can see on
the outside that I did it by looking at
a public key and also in in
cryptocurrencies and blockchains uh this
whole idea of public key cryptography is
extensively used um and uh it's um there
are many protocols there are many sort
of ways to factor this idea of there's a
different key to encrypt and to
decrypt so that's a that's a big place
where where factoring numbers is is uh
uh is used well actually it's the
inability to factor numbers that's used
and people will often wonder oh if we
had a faster better stronger computer
maybe a Quantum compter computer or
something could we take all these things
which people have assumed can't be
factored and just crack them all my
guess is no and my guess is it's a quite
separate story that about why quantum
computers won't work to do that one of
the things that was sort of a big break
in the in the kind of idea of quantum
computers is happened in the
1990s um a thing called shaes algorithm
was was developed that is a way of
factoring numbers using a quantum
computer well the problem is that what
what more or less happens in a quantum
computer the big idea is that instead of
there being a particular sequence of
instructions that are performed quantum
mechanics allows you to sort of have
many threads of history that you can
sort of have running in parallel sort of
all at the same time and then at the end
of it you just have to say well what was
the result from that knowing the result
is a hard thing and that's something we
figured out with our physics project
some estimates of the difficulty of sort
of untangling a a Quantum uh Computing
process like that but the idea for
factoring is roughly that well uh you
use all these different Quantum threads
and each Quantum thread is trying a
different number to divide the the
number you started with by and so
remember if you if you could just go
through if you have the number a million
and you could just work out for every
number up to a million you could just
say does it divide that is it divisible
by that number can I can I divide it in
in as whole numbers with that number etc
etc etc with 2 3 4 five six and so on I
do all those trial divisions if I can do
all those trial divisions then I can
know whether my I can know what the
factors of my number are so the idea for
a quantum computer is let's get all
those parallel threads of History each
thread is doing one trial division more
or
less so that sounds really good it's
like oh we'll be able to do this the
problem is that when you want to measure
the result when you want to to figure
out what actually happened which thread
you know yes one of these threads
successfully was effective for the
number but it's like well what actually
happened which thread was it where did
it go that turns out to be really hard
because we humans don't aren't sensitive
to all these separate threads of History
we we sort of knit all those threads of
History together to believe that
definite things happen in the world and
so that's a piece that isn't part of the
kind of mathematical formalism of
quantum mechanics so it's hard to kind
of estimate how difficult it is to do
that knitting together but it seems to
be pretty hard so it seems like this
idea that you'll be able to use the sort
of quantum parallelism to always work
out solve these factoring problems I
don't think it's going to it's going to
pan out so anyway that's a that's a big
sort of use case for factoring in the
world actually it's for not factoring is
the really the big use case there are
gosh there are so many places where uh
in practice one wants to do these things
let me give you a just a very everyday
example you got a bunch of pictures and
you're going to make an array of
pictures and you're going to put it on
your page and i' I've been in the
situation many times how many pictures
should I have well if I have 18 pictures
I can make a um you know I can make um
three * six or I can make two * N I can
lay out my pictures in those arrays if I
have a prime number of pictures while
I'm I'm out of luck um you know there's
no way to lay them out in a rectangle so
to speak but that's a very practical
place where oh yep you need to know the
factors of a number to know how do you
get to lay out your pictures in a nice
in a nice
array
uh let's
see
um okay there's a question
here
a petel
asks
um I'm not sure I quite understand this
question but it has to do with so-called
one-way functions that's what happens in
the case of factoring and multiplying
things together the you can multiply
stuff together one way but going
backwards that is breaking the number up
the thing that you can make the number
out of by multiplying is hard so that's
a so-called one-way function where you
can go one way but you can't go back one
place in physics where um which I've
studied a lot uh well from for 50 years
actually but I think I finally um uh
have a a decent resolution and wrote a
book about this recently is in the
second law of Thermodynamics the law of
entropy increase the law that says that
things tend to get more random you put
gas molecules in a box they Bounce
Around they'll tend to look more random
in their configurations than when you
started um the that phenomenon is a
phenomenon very much like encryption and
that phenomenon is this kind of oneway
type thing where through this process
that through this phenomenon I call
computational irreducibility you know
the rules by which these molecules are
bouncing around and those individual
rules are completely reversal like you
can say oh the molecules bounced this
way and out that way or they could have
started out that way and bounced back
this way so each individual Collision is
reversible but together you've got a
sufficiently complicated computation
that's going on that you can't uh figure
out the reversal of those things or a
typical Observer like us looking at
these gas molecules won't figure that
out so that's a kind of a big big use
case of the whole story of sort of
one-way functions is this idea of the
the randomness of things tends to
increase and that's that's a that's
that's something very similar to
encryption that it is it the randomness
tends to increase you can't go backwards
you know I've tried to find public key
cryptography systems that work on
different kinds of mathematical bases or
computational bases this one about
factoring is a real good example where
you know you multiply the numbers
together you get something which is hard
to go backwards on there's a question of
of other other kind of structures where
it works that way so for example in the
case of this uh sort of encryption done
by the gas molecules bouncing around you
can idealize that by something where you
just have lines of black and white cells
and you have some rule that says how
blocks of those black and white cells
can be replaced by by new cells that
makes these things called cellular
autometa that I've studied a whole bunch
and I I wondered a lot particularly in
the 1980s was there a way of using
cellular autometer to make a public key
crypto system I never succeeded in doing
that and nor as anybody else since I
don't think one can you know there's no
way to know that it's not possible we
couldn't figure out how to do it um the
the same kind of idea with cellular
autometer you can have sort of oh this
cellular autometer can be applied and
then that one that's kind of like
multiplying numbers together it's like
multiplying cellular autometer and is
there a way of taking the combined
cellular autometer and finding out that
the the pieces the in the sort of prime
cellular autometer from which it's built
are hard to get to know that that isn't
a hard problem so it's there wasn't the
same kind of thing as with numbers the
only common
other sort of um uh method for making um
public key crypto systems is so-called
elliptic curve cryptography which is
number thing another thing that's based
on kind of number Theory I can roughly
EXP explain how that works maybe uh so
remember I mentioned X2 + y^2 = z^2 and
and what are the integer values of X Y
and Z that make that that that satisfy
that equation so 345 is an example that
satisfies that equation okay let's take
the equation x^2 + y cubed equals
something little bit funkier a little
bit you know a little bit more
complicated that that equation if you
kind of plotted out what the what the
possible values of X and Y are if they
were arbitrary real numbers you could
figure out what those numbers could be
and you would get this thing called an
elliptic curve and then the question is
are there integer values or actually
rational values rational numbers that
satisfy that equation what are the what
is so the rational points on an tic
curve and it turns out there's a whole
elaborate Theory relates to group Theory
and so on of uh what possible rational
points there can be on elliptic curves
and the that sort of story of going from
one set of points to another set of
points and so on is something that's
kind of like factoring versus
multiplying and you can build uh other
another kind of problem that's like the
factoring problem that is sort of easy
to do one way and hard to do it the
other way and so there's a whole bunch
of uh key crypto systems that are based
on elliptic curves and there's it's kind
of like they they they come in little
species where there's a particular
elliptic curve one elliptic curve it's
like oh we're using the you know EC 184
you know whatever no it's that's not
right that that's a I I forget the
designations of the elliptic curves um
but we're using this named branded
elliptic curve and then you can work out
all sorts of properties of it and things
get kind of complicated because uh in
the in the practicalities of of the
world uh something like the National
Security Agency in the US that's
responsible for government cryptography
and so on is uh will say we've got
elliptic curve here it is this is we
here are its properties use this
elliptic curve and then people get all
suspicious oh why are you giving us this
elliptic curve you know it must be an
elliptic curve that you've somehow
cracked so that's a there's a whole sort
of uh scal dugery of elliptic curves
that people sometimes bring
up
um the let's see uh oh by the way I
should have mentioned when I was talking
about cellular autometer I never figured
out how to make a public key crypto
system but cellular autometer are great
for private key cryptography because
they're very good at making Randomness
and the key is just what configuration
you start the thing off from once you
start it off from that configuration
just run the rules you get this pattern
the pattern has lots of random features
you can use that random
to uh encrypt your message so so roughly
here's how it works let's say your
message is a bunch of ones and zeros and
your message is 11 one 0000 Z okay now
let's say that you have generated a
sequence that is for all practical
purposes random you did it using a
little key but that one little key is
enough once you once you to run the
cellular automatone you get this long
sequence 1 0 0 1 1 0 whatever a random
looking
sequence all you do is you take that
random looking sequence and every time
there's a one you flip the bit in your
message every time it's a zero you don't
flip the bit so if we've got one one one
z0 Z and we've say the the the first
pieces of our sort of ciphering stream
one1 then that 111 at the beginning will
turn into zero because we flipped that
first bit one because we didn't flip the
next Bit Zero because we flipped the
next bit and so what you need so you
encrypt by just sort of combining you're
doing exclusive or operation combining
or some mod 2 operation for each bit you
combine it with one bit in the sequence
that you got out often called the key
sequence that's a little bit confusing
because the key is really the thing you
did to start the whole thing off but
you're generating this whole long
sequence of seemingly random bits you
combine that with your plain text your
original message then you get your
Cipher text which is you know every bit
has been essentially randomly flipped
and to go back all you need is that key
sequence and you do the same operation
again and if you flipped if it was a if
it was a one in the key sequence caused
you to flip then if you apply the key
sequence again you'll flip again and
you'll get back to what you started from
again so that's a way to make a uh a
non-public key Cipher where it's the
same sort of uh the same key original
key that you use to get what you need to
en Cipher to encrypt as to decrypt and
so that's and that's something you can
do very nicely very well with cellular
autometer uh something I made up in the
1980s and I guess has been quite a lot
used since then so that that's a um uh
um
so let's see
uh
my questions here about
um
um how can we prove that there's
Randomness on a big scale oh that's a
big can of
worms what does it mean that something
is random what it means is one can't see
a pattern in it well how does
one sort of a question is how does one
look for that pattern let me give you an
example the digits of pi so far as we
know those digits don't have an obvious
pattern to them but of course at some
level they have a pattern because they
are the digits of pi and that's
something we can say about them that we
can't say about other digit
sequences but on the other hand if we
say well do the same number of ones and
twos occur in the decimal digits of pi
so far as we know the same number of
ones and twos occur on average so
there's nothing special about that
aspect of of the sequence but this
question about when sort of what counts
us random and you can start asking
questions like if you if you bash the
sequence with sort of all possible
computations up to some level of
difficulty of the computations will you
guarantee that you can't find a pattern
you can't find a regularity you can't
compress the sequence with any comp with
any comput computation that's below some
level of difficulty of the computation
and that's something which you can
potentially with certain footnotes show
in certain cases so that's sort of a a a
conditional definition of
Randomness um by the way the whole issue
of doing crypto analysis the whole issue
of kind of can you figure out what uh
what key was used to make this encrypted
message that's all about finding
regularities breaking out the pure
Randomness so for example key fact is if
you're encrypting a piece of English
text then when assuming that every
letter is encrypted the encrypted
version of every letter is just another
letter like this T turned into a z this
H turned into a q etc etc etc well the
the point is that the original text has
certain regularities so for example
there are more E's than than Z's in the
original text
a t is often followed by an H etc etc
etc a q is usually followed by a u those
kinds of things those kinds of
regularities are what allow you to sort
of tease out regularities from the
apparent randomness of an encrypted
message and that's sort of the essence
of crypto analysis is to find those
kinds of regularities and the question
whether Crypt analysis is even possible
depends on whether well it depends on
the fact that your original message had
certain regularities in it and in
particular one of the things this was
discovered probably discovered during
World War II it wasn't written up until
Claude Shannon did it in the late 1940s
um it was probably discovered um earlier
than that um
that there was this notion of what
turned into information Theory this idea
of well in that particular instance of
this it's when you
do you do all letters occur with equal
frequency okay no they don't um what is
the if we're going to predict the next
letter what you know we can if we're
going to say what's the most likely next
letter it's going to be an e if we know
nothing else predict e you'll be right
more of the time than if you predict Z
for example if you start making a longer
block like you've seen that it says t uh
th okay what's next actually quite
possibly e is next next um certainly Z
is very unlikely to be next if you had
th so uh you can you can start sort of
increasing you can say well what are the
probabilities for next letters to be
this or that thing and that the question
of sort of how far you can get by just
saying how far you can reproduce a
message by just saying what are the
probabilities is sort of something which
turns into the information content of
the message it in so far as it's it's um
uh yeah and so by the way zooming to the
current time llms large language models
like chat gbt they are all about kind of
based on the probabilities of what came
before what is the most likely thing to
come next and they're doing that not for
letters but for words or tokens pieces
of words and they're asking the question
given that you saw the cat sat on the
what is the most likely next word and
there they're basically saying given the
things that we see the examples that we
see in a few billion web pages what is
the most likely next word there and the
real trick with large language models
which wasn't obvious it was going to
work at all is that well yes in that
particular case there probably enough
instances on the web of the catat on the
mat or whatever that we could just look
at the statistics of the web to figure
out what the next word was but most of
the time most of the long prompts you
might give to chat gbt they don't exist
anywhere on the web so it's kind of got
to got to extrapolate from what it's
seen on the web it's going to make a
model that allows it to predict what the
next word is likely to be and the fact
that that model can be made using neural
Nets that's the big surprise and the
fact that when the model once made seems
to make same kinds of predictions that
humans would make that's the big
surprise that's the thing that really
made has made large language models take
off presumably the reason it makes
predictions that are about the same as
what humans would make is because the
architecture of these neural Nets is at
least close enough to the architecture
of the neurons in our brains that sort
of the same kinds of things
happen
uh Eli is asking could there be an
inverse to the lore of entropy increase
something like that under certain
conditions structural organization
always increases which maybe gives rise
to something like biological evolution
yeah that's a very interesting question
um you know Darwin Charles Darwin
believed that sort of the increase in
complexity of biology was inevitable he
has a nice quote the very last line of
his Origin of Species book was something
like as the earth goes circling around
the Sun according to the fixed law of
gravity so ever more complex organisms
you know are being evolved I'm
paraphrasing a bit he thought that there
was a law as inexorable as the law of
gravity that gets you know planets to
keep orbiting things that there would be
some inexorable consequence of natural
selection that would cause progressively
more complex organisms to be produced
that seems not to be true often and we
see it not only in natural selection in
biology but in technology and other
places often there's a Simple Solution
that's really good and it blows
everything else away so it doesn't Force
the increase of
complexity now the the the sort of I
have to say that for
myself the the more that I understand
biology the more surprising it seems at
some level in the sense that one might
have said well biology is just like
chemistry there are a bunch of you know
we have we have the right kinds of
molecules and they're bouncing around
and they have chemical reactions and
they do the right thing that seems to
not be what's happening in biology what
seems to be happening is that right down
the scale of individual molecules
molecules are being carefully uh pushed
in the right direction they're being
transported down Little Fibers they're
being oriented by by fitting into little
gaps in this shape of a protein molecule
or something they're being they're being
everything is kind of being
organized and that process of kind of
that sort of orchestrated thing that is
biology is a really remarkable thing now
we've seen other examples we see it in
technology we see it in software systems
it isn't the case that the electrons in
a microprocessor that are carrying the
electrical signals are bouncing around
randomly no they're bouncing around
they're being organized by the details
of a program that's causing them to have
you know a one here a zero there these
things are added to that this gate is
open that one's closed and so on it's
all
orchestrated but now the question is is
is there a bulk theory of orchestration
that is we can say about when we have
our molecules and they're just bouncing
around and so on we can make Global
statements about the fact that there is
this tendency for the molecules to seem
like they're configured in a more and
more random way but is there is there a
situation in biology for example where
there is sort of maybe inevitable maybe
just it it has been set up that way or
maybe as we build the Software System
we're gradually adding more and more to
the software system what can we say in
in in global terms about sort of the
orchestration of all those pieces I
think it's a very interesting question
and I don't know um it's something where
I think that there are certain
quantitative laws that are pretty common
like it's very very common to find power
laws show up it's very common like a
common one not really not in biology
although versions of this show up in
biology if you look at the words in the
English language and you rank them from
the most common word to the least common
word and you'll have some ambiguities
because it depends on exactly which text
you looked at and so on but roughly the
word roseros is less common than the
word the and so we get some rough
ranking now the nth most common word if
we rank them all from the most common to
the least common and so on seems to have
frequency about 1 / n that's called
Zip's law and nobody knows quite why
it's true there are some simple ways you
can guess why it might be true why
languages might have evolved to have
that form why you can get that kind of
law just by saying you put down letters
at random with spaces in between and and
uh you can kind of and then you sort of
burn in the results and so on you can
get that there a variety of ways to get
something like that but why that
actually occurs and power laws like that
that's just power to the minus one but
but other kinds of Power laws are pretty
common to see in lots of kinds of
complicated systems a complicated
particularly complicated more
orchestrated systems and you know to
have this theory of why that happens to
have sort of a theory of orchestrated
systems is an interesting thing I've
been thinking about it I don't know how
to do it um and what kinds of questions
you might be able to ask about those
systems is another interesting issue
because if you say well what in detail
does it do well you have to go right
down into into into all of the details
of the system and you're really not
going to be able to answer that other
than by essentially running the system
and seeing what happens so what kinds of
global statements can you expect to make
you know could you expect to make a
statement like oh biological organisms
will always eventually die because the
orchestration will eventually fail
somehow is that a general statement you
can make I don't know if that one is
even true it's not true for some cell
lines and things like this so it's it's
not um but you know are there what kinds
of statements might you be able to make
and I think that's uh that's something
very much um an open question that uh I
at least have been have been interested
in um about uh uh sort of the the you're
getting something where there
isn't Randomness in the sense that you
just say oh my best approximation to
this is we pick these things with
certain probabilities and that's all we
can say it's clear that there's
organization but you can't you can't
make statements about that organization
just by other than by saying oh well
look I can see that it's organized type
thing all right well we should probably
wrap up in a moment here let me see if
there's anything else that relates to
the topics we've been talking about
here
uh
[Music]
um memes is commenting here are there
really an infinite amount of primes yes
there absolutely are and uclid showed
that uh if you start asking for while I
mentioned the twin primes case there are
lots of other sort of special kinds of
primes and asking whether there are
infinite number of those special kinds
of primes those are typically unanswered
questions
questions uh for example um one example
is primes of the form 4 n + one where n
is an integer and of the form 4 n minus
one uh that right those are those you
can kind of say well how many primes are
there one form versus how many of the
other form and you have these kind of
two curves and they're going up and down
and chasing each other and um the uh you
know it's not known whether what what
sort of the outcome of that will be
actually it reminds me of another thing
about primes you guys were asking me
about um kind of surprising thing about
about primes here's one so this prime
number theorem that gives you an
estimate of the number of
primes there's a formula in the prime
number theorem that gives you that
estimate and it seems for a long time
that the number of actual number of
primes is depending on how you set it up
either less than or greater than what
this estimate says it seems like this
estimate is always overestimating or
always underestimating depending on how
you set it up the the actual number of
primes and that seems to be true for a
long long way in fact ranuan famous
Indian mathematician from the early part
of the 20th century who came up with
many surprising results that I think he
derived by doing sort of calculation and
experimental mathematics and then said
oh by the way this weird weird formula
with square roots of pies and square
roots of 17s and things and it happens
to be true he found that by doing
calculation and then uh you know then he
like this is true he actually thought
that he had found a proof of the prime
number theorem um and therefore a proof
of the ran hypothesis uh using um the uh
uh and that you would always have but
actually didn't say had a proof he said
this thing will always be this this
estimate will always be greater than the
number of primes um but he did that by
you know sort of evidence for the fact
that he used this kind of experimental
method because that result is true up to
very very very big numbers there's
something called the Skuse number which
is like 10 the^ 10 the^
10ish don't remember exactly what what
it is but it's a very big number it's a
number so big that you couldn't write
out its digits on atoms in the universe
and have it fit so it's known that this
estimate will flip over at least by that
number could it flip over much much
sooner than that but it's known that you
go far enough out the number of primes
will will end up being let's say greater
than instead of less than this estimate
so that's another sort of surprising
thing about the primes I mean I think
the the big picture of the primes is
they're always they've always got
surprises and it is very
surprising that something whose
definition is as simple as the
definition of the primes could have an
infinite collection of surprises and in
a sense that's deeply related I think to
this idea of computational
irreducibility the idea that you can set
up rules for a system that can be quite
simple and yet as you actually run the
system you will always have surprises
and if you keep going and you're going
to bigger and bigger and bigger and
bigger primes you'll always have
surprises um and that it's also related
to Good's theorem about uh the the fact
that there are proofs of infinite length
in axiomatic systems like the one that's
used in in studying properties of
numbers and so on so it's kind of the
fact that the primes always bring in
surprises is uh a
um uh is itself a very interesting fact
about the world and about mathematics
and so on I think that point that sort
of the primes bring in surprises is
something I suppose people have really
concentrated in mathematics on the
unsurprising aspects the smooth the
predictable aspects of primes
something that's more been something
I've been interested in is these cases
where you have sort of the unpredictable
the necessarily unpredictable happening
and it's something where even back in
Antiquity uh
people uh knew a certain number of
primes I mean uh you know Plato for
example was very big on the fact that
what is the number is it 4,40 I can't
remember there's some number that Plato
describes as being an optimal number for
the size of a Democratic Society or
something because it's a number that has
many factors talking about factoring
there's another application of factoring
for you uh what is that number it's it's
around 4,000 something I think and so
the fact that they knew how to factor
that number means they must have known
you know primes up to on the order of
that number and yet this observation
that the distribution of primes seems
kind of random that's not an observation
you see anywhere you see people
discussing well can we find regularities
but not oh it seems kind of random what
is the significance of
that all right well thanks for asking
bunch of interesting questions there and
uh I should uh go back to my day job and
look forward to chatting with you again
another time bye for
now